[Music]
grab the microphone and let your words
now here's a funky introduction to how
nice I am tell your mother tell your
father send the telegram I'm like an
Energizer no are you okay okay what the
hell is that I don't know was that the
same thing that happened with the
microwave
you tell me no God maybe your stereo is
just old with your stupid music
today we have the story that's going to
change the world yes it's in Nigeria
electricity coming out of their hands
all teenage girls mom I know some can
like aim it how does yours work
hey hey
there was one girl I'd say was a
mutation but it's hundreds and thousands
I'm a journalist
I want to tell your story
it's gonna change things
what did you do the World As We Know It
may never be the same
this is pretty scary her powers will
freak me out Charles you got this thing
we all do
got it because we need it
I'm gonna have trouble smile for me
oh you look nice when you smile
they're testing everyone I have to keep
people safe
this is invasive it's unethical I'm just
asking for a list you're gonna treat our
kids like criminals
feel something different about her she
has done amazing things
I did it
dad let me come work for you cause I can
help what you want my dad's money
[Music]
I didn't even realize that I was living
in constant here I want to see the world
how you see
it how has made me see how well that
could be better for all of us
I just feel like a hundred pounds
lighter
times stronger
um
can you imagine growing up with that
kind of freedom
[Applause]
[Music]